abone ol
ne biçim aerocool superomedial O bir
tukul Pego Evet sizlere kendi lisanımla
selamladım Ben çocukken Ben ablamı
yatağına uzanıp odasındaki dev manzara
resmine bakarak Bu anlamsız sesleri
mırıldanır ve bu şekilde dünyadaki bütün
insanlarla konuşabileceğim Hayal ederdim
Köpekler Kediler solucanlarla konuşurdum
özellikle üstüme koymasınlar diye
sinekleri konuşarak ikna ederdim doğrusu
bunda da çok iyiydim evden okula okuldan
eve yürüyerek gidip gelirdim şimdi mewo
gördüm bütün bitkiler ve ağaçlarla
konuşurdum sanırım o yıllarda birçok
şeyi seslendirme mewo kendi kendime
konuşmam içimdeki birçok sesinde
uyanmasına vesile oldu
bu oldukça yaramaz bir çocuktum sokakta
oynamaya bayılırdım Arkadaşlarımla çok
farklı oyunlar kurardım şu mi iyi bir
Çocukluğum oldum fakat bir şey vardı
benim için çok özel annemin dikiş
makinası
bu ahşap dolap şeklindeki makine
açıldığı vakit yüzü açık kalırdı onu bir
ölçüyle kapar dım dım yanıma alıştıra
bileceğim ufak tefek yiyecekler alır
tuvalete gitmemek adına da kum kafamın
ve Bütün günümü bu 90'a 90 bu dikiş
makinesinin altında Hayaller kurarak
geçirdim
Ben bugün hala çok fazla hayal kuran
biri birisiyim Elbette gerçek hayatta
hayallerimin hepsini gerçekleştirme
mümkün değil ama bu kadar çok hayal
bolluğun içinde
Elbette
elimde gene çok fazla gerçek Tek
bildiğim Hayal kalıyor birçok çocuk gibi
Hatta yetişkin gibi ben de deniz
kenarında sahilde Kumlu oynamayı çok
severdim özellikle dalgaların ıslattığı
sulu kumu alarak Peri bacalarını
anımsatan kaleler yapılar yapardım ve
bazen bir dalga gelir onu alıp
götürürdüm Ama bunun pek önemsemez dim
Çünkü oradaki oyun hali çok güzeldi
Günün Sonunda eve Gitmem gerektiğinde
gene yaptıklarımı başına ne geleceğini
odaklanma lazım düşünmezdim onu gene bir
dalga alabilirdi ya da insanlar plajda
yürürken ayaklarıyla edebilirlerdi Ben
zaten orada oyun halinden çok mutluyum
mutluyum
mutluyum dedim ister istemez Çünkü hala
bu
süreç benim için çok önemli yapıp
ettiklerine olacağından ziyade o sürece
bir meditasyon hali gibi yaşamak ve ve
kendimi bırakma hali gerçekten emsalsiz
bir durum
lise hayatım oldukça sıkıcıydı Çünkü
derslere odaklanamaz dım dım ne zaman
ders çalışmam gerekse Defter ve
kitaplarını açsam onları karalamaya
resim yapmaya başladım Böylelikle güzel
sanatlara daire bir şey yapacağımı
düşündüm ve sıkıla sıkıla mecburen
hedefine ulaşmak için o liseyi bitirdim
sonunda en çok girmek istediğim bölüm
güzel sanatlarda endüstri ürünleri
tasarımı na girdim
Maalesef ki okulun ikinci senesinde
okuldan Hayal ettiklerimi bulamadım
tasarım anlayışları ve eğitim sistemi
hiç bana göre değildi
ben o zamana kadar zaten istemediğim bir
eğitim sisteminde mecbur kalmıştım ve
artık o günden sonra istemediğim bir şey
yapmamaya karar verdim Böylelikle
Londra'da bir politik te takı yapmaya
ittim
İstanbul'a döndükten sonra
Kapalıçarşı'da kendi kreasyonlarını
yaptım
ve önce İstanbul'da sonra Ankara'da
olmak üzere bunları sergiledim küçük
heykeller başlığı altında
gerçekten de yaptıklarım buçuk heykeller
di mi etrafımda sözlerine çok değer
verdiğim dostlarım kişiler ahsene gel
yapıyorsun Belki de heykel yapmalısın
dediler görünen oydu gerçekten minik
şekerler yapıyordum Böylelikle O Gün
itibariyle heykel yapmaya başladım Hala
da heykel yapıyorum Evet ben birçok
farklı disiplinlerde İşler üretsem de bu
boncukta yaptım soyut heykeller ile
bilinen bir sanatçıyım bu solutech
ellerin formları da organik dünyaya ait
oluyorlar
sizlere yaptığım bazı çalışmaları
paylaşmak istiyorum Bu çalışmaları
seyirler üzerine ne yaptım İlk olarak
Costa mayanın görsellerini
göstererek
onlardan bahsetmek istiyorum
Costa Maya serisinde bir form Yarattım
atölyeme gitti mi bitmiş bir form
Yarattım çalıştıktan sonra Sonra Bu
formunu olduk olmadık yerlerinden deldim
delik deşik gerçekten Paramparça ve
görüntü çıktı ortaya Ve o an daha onunla
Ne yapacağımı bilemedim gerçekten Çünkü
sahne işte hoş değildi çöpe atasım geldi
Dursun sönmek gerekiyorsa Evet
Ee
İçimdeki ses buradan Evet görüyoruz
ekranlarda Costa Maya serisine İçimdeki
ses
bunu nasıl iyileştirebilirim Ne
yapabilirim nasıl ve nasıl buradan
çıkabilirim e kendime göre nasıl bir yol
haritası bulabilirim dedim gerçekten bu
delikleri anlamsız delikleri bir bir
kendi form anlayışında oluşturabilmek
oldukça el olay oyalayan bir süreçte
Sonuçta 5-6 parça heykel çıktıktan sonra
onlara şöyle bir baktığımda
bu formüllerin Bu zamana kadar yapmadım
şekilde incelmiş çok delikli neredeyse
Koptu Kopacak gibi haller aldıklarını ve
kemiksin hatta sünger silisi yapılar
olduğunu fark ettim bu Maalesef o
dönemde Türkiye'nin çeşitli yerlerinde
de birçok bombalar patlıyordu sokaklarda
cansız bedenlere parçalanmış bedenlere
bi şarkı gitmiştik bu tip görüntüleri ve
ilginç bir şekilde Benim de kişisel
hayatımda büyük bir parçalanma söz
konuşuyorum
meh bu kadar kemiksi yapıdan bütün
bunları da fark ederek kendi kendime ah
bu benim kaburga dedim
ve Latince
hoşlanmaya benim kaburgam demek seviye
Costa Maya ismini verdim Bu seride ilk
defa hiç kullanmadım çarpıcı parlak
renkleri kullandım Hatta bakış açısına
göre renk değiştiren boyalar kullandım
heykellerimi tavandan sallandırdı mım
bazıları kendi eksenlerinde döndü yukarı
aşağı hareket ettiler Böylelikle a de
Sabir yok kuşağı efekti yaratmış oldum
sanki bütün bu parçalanmışlar rağmen
yıkılmadım ayaktayım dertlerimle bir
çağırma olduğunu düşünün
koşturmaya serisini hazırladığım da
atölyemi bir dostum geldim ve Ah Bunlar
ne kadar güzel işte böyle ne kadar
akışkan gözüm böyle üstünde geziyor
harikulade vesaire gibi böyle çok tatlı
iltifatlarda bulundu Sonra dedi ki Ay
keşke dedi bul delikleri den içeri
girebilecek Çünkü Gözümüz sadece bir
noktaya kadar kavga biliyor Hadi bunun
içinede girebilecek ne kadar güzel bir
şey olur dedi Ben de ona bunu istiyorsan
sana bunu yaşatırım dedim ve böylelikle
cost almayayım
alarak Seriye ismini veren heykeli
alarak bir yazacağız yazıcıdan geçirdim
ve böylelikle e-postamı Hanım Bütün
dataları Bilgisayar ortamında geçtim ben
bilgisayara uzak bir insanım
Bana bu bu yolculuğu animasyonu
yapabilmesi için bir arkadaşımdan destek
aldım ve onunla çalışırken Hadi gel şu
delikten girelim şuradan sağ dönelim
yukarı bakalım neler olacak gibi bir
animasyon hazırladık bütün heykelin
içinde dolaşa bileceğimiz bir ambulans
oluştu Böylelikle
animasyonla beraber animasyonu
çalışırken
ortaya çıkan bazı render görüntüleri
Beni o kadar çok büyüledi ki bu
görüntüleri de sevgimde kullanmak
istedim yasak adı verilen birtakım
baskılar yaptım ve kostüm ayı bu şekilde
oluşturdum
ikinci göstermek istediğim de anlatmak
istediğim Sevim Hatıralar Bu putlara
hatıralarla mektuplar serisine
başlamadan önce bana o zamana kadar
birçok yazı yazmış
eleştiriler yapmış röportajlar
yaptığımız Profesör Doktor Markus grafa
sanat tarihçileri traktördür kendisi bir
mektup yazdım ve gelecek dönemde bir
sevgim olduğunu bu sergiyi belgelemek
için onunla daha farklı bir üslupla ve
su bulaşarak bu Seriye belgelemek
istediğimi söyledim Markus teklifi kabul
etti de mektuplaşma ya başladık Tabii
saat kalem o kadar unuttum hele mektup o
kadar unuttuğun bir şey deki Cihat ve
kalemle kurduğum bu ilişki ile beraber
yeni serimde düz metal levhaları tıpkı
bir kağıt gibi olan metal yasaları kendi
sanat pratiğinde ki form anlayışında
dönüştürmeye başladım Ha bu arada
sürekli markası mektup yazıyordum olup
bitenlere dair aynı zamanda yazma hali
beni çok fazla geçmişe götürdü bütün
hatıralarım
canlandım Aynı zamanda da bu içindeki
seslerin hepsi yazıyla beraber o kadar
çok akışkan bir hal aldı ki
yazınında so mutlu ile beraber daha da
ortaya çıktılar ve böylelikle sanat
pratiğinde ilk defa yazının kendisi Eser
oldu bunlardan bir tanesi Piece of Art
bunu bir tuval üzerine adapte ettim bir
diğeri de paslanmaz çelikle yazdım Buna
baktıkça beni hatırla yazılar oldu
mektuplaşma ya Kendimi o kadar çok
kaptırmıştım ki ve çok zevk almıştım
başka kişileri de mektuplar yazmak
istedim
bu ve Costa Maya serisinde yaptım yasak
görüntülerini alarak PTT'ye kişisel
pullar bastırdım Böylelikle
tanıdığım tanımadığım birçok kişiye
Mektup yazdım Yazdım bu mektupların
içine bastırdım pulları koydum kişiler
bana okulları kullanarak yeri mektuplar
yazdılar ve
hoşlanmaya serisindeki diğer Sen eklerim
dolaşım açıldı çok daha fazla kişiye
ulaşmış oldu Böylelikle
son olarak bu Seriye dair bir pazar
günüydü
oğlumun odasına girdim
az Çalışma masasının üstüne resim
defteri açıktı böyle ister istemez
birşeyler karalamaya başladım ne kadar
zaman geçti bilmiyorum ama epey bir
zaman geçti sonradan farkettim ve
karakalem Desenler yapmıştım kendime
durduramaz bir şekilde bu desenleri
yapmaya Evet devam etme arzusuyla bu
desenlerinde Hatıralar mektuplar
serisinin son parçaları oldular seri
bütün seriler ya da bütün çalışma
sürecim sinirler üzerinde özellikle
sürecek kendimi bırakmam bazı
tesadüfleri Hatta bazı tesadüfleri kendi
yaratma halimle e oluştuğunu düşünüyorum
Bir başka göstermek istedim çalışmamda
İzmir'deki demokrasi ve dayanışma Anıtı
olacak
bir yarışmanın neticesinde oluşmuş bir
projede Bu yarışmaya davet edildiğinde
katılmak istemedim çünkü benzer bir
yarışma olduğundan
daha önceden etik olmayan birçok şeye
rastlamış ve son derece kırılmıştım
Oysa bu bu konsepti izmirdeniz
projesiydi ve kavramı dalgaların kıyıya
bıraktı izin referans mıydı bu o kadar
çok bana dair O kadar çok benim saat
kredi ve yapışmış bir kavram da kim ona
Kayıtsız kalamadım İyi ki de Kalamadım
Böylelikle Türkiye'de bu açıkta yapılmış
iç iç soyut Anıtı da yapmış olur evet
içimizdeki sesler diyoruz
son olarak Benden bu tedex konuşması
yapmam istendiğinde İçimdeki ses ses
yapma dedim Çünkü ben kendimi konuşarak
ifade eden bir kişi değilim
yaptıklarımla bağır olduğumu ya da bu
şekilde ortaya düştü mü düşünüyorum
endişelendim Çünkü ben bu cümleye
başlarım O cümlenin içindeki bir
kelimeye kapılırım ona serbest
çağrışımla başka başka yerlere
gidebilirim Oysa içindeki bu süreci yaşa
dedi Umarım hepimiz içimizdeki seslerle
münazara edebilir ve süreçten keyif
alabiliriz Günnur Özsoy korosunu
dinlediğiniz için Hepinize çok teşekkür
ediyorum